wir wollen jetzt auch mit unserer bild
reporterin franziska von mutius sprechen
sie hat die beiden auch lange begleitet
und du hast auch die informationen von
der schwester was weißt du mehr über die
hintergründe des tods von sigrid ja ich
hab mir schwester hannelore gesprochen
die natürlich tief traurig ist aber sie
sagt es ist eine ganz große erlösung
gewesen er hatte ja keine chance und es
ist richtig was der kollege mark geben
erzählt hat sie wollte eigentlich mit
ihm gemeinsam bieten sie hat sie anrufen
lassen noch eine halbe stunde bevor er
gestorben ist und er konnte aber nicht
mehr sprechen und nicht mehr reagieren
aber sie hat für ihn gebetet was er auch
gehört hat sie hat das vaterunser für
ihn gebetet und mein herr und mein gott
und er hat dann ganz schwierig noch eine
sache sagen können nämlich okay
und sie hat gesagt siegfried sei ganz
ruhig ich hab dich fans an der hand und
ich bin den herzens gedanken bei dir und
dann haben sie aufgelegt und eine halbe
stunde später ist er heim gegangen und
sie sagt sie ist fest davon überzeugt
dass diese gebete ihnen den mut gegeben
haben loszulassen und er sei jetzt in
seinem neuen leben gut angekommen
ja sehr bewegend was du uns dass
schilder das vielleicht können wir noch
mal gemeinsam auf dieses magier duo
zurückschauen was hatte roy und
siegfried und roy so einzigartig gemacht
ich glaube der erfolg von den beiden war
so ungewöhnlich weil sie selbst daran
überhaupt gar nicht geglaubt haben zu
anfang sie sind ja zwei ganz normale
jungs gewesen die es sozusagen geschafft
haben vom tellerwäscher auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff zu multimillionären zu
werden
das geld war ihnen gar nicht so wichtig
sondern das lachen der menschen der
applaus hat sie über 40 jahre immer
weiter angetrieben auf die bühne zu
gehen um menschen glücklich zu machen
und das ist etwas was mich persönlich
tief traurig macht ich hatte das glück
die beiden letztes jahr für bild vier
wochen in münchen zu begleiten und ich
habe selten jemanden getroffen der so
erfolgreichen so bekannt ist die aber
menschlich so liebenswert waren und auch
miteinander so unglaublich toll
umgegangen sind die waren eine einheit
die sich eigentlich in den letzten
jahren immer nur um andere noch
gekümmert haben und den menschen die
wünsche von den augen abgelesen haben
die sie natürlich auch aufgrund ihres
erfolges
wirklich geben konnten und dass die 2
zum einen so schrecklich getrennt wurden
im vergangenen jahr durch den tod von
reue
siegried so eine schwere krankheit
bekommen hat das hat mich traurig
gemacht
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren